hey folks and welcome to generation next
on this week's show we're going to be
looking ahead to 2021
the games we're looking forward to
playing on ps5 and xbox series x
as well as features that we hope are
going to be coming to the new consoles
joining me as ever is xbox expert jordan
remain what's up
and playstation pro tomorrow hussain
hello everyone how are we today
doing all right thanks tom any personal
attacks on me lucy this week
um
again she did you dirty last week can i
just say that when you tweeted out that
clip you very
conveniently left off the bit where you
tried to do a reverse dunk on me
and it just failed so
let's put that out there no i don't have
any dunks yet but
we still have time
okay jordan which 2021 game are you most
looking forward to
hollow knight silk song which i just
assume at this point must be 2021
because
team cherry has not said anything
about this game since december 2019
other than the fact that they're working
on it and which i assumed meant
2020 but given that we're now days
away from the year ending i'm like
i assume just now 2021 it has to be it
has to be so i'm going to say just
because a peep behind the curtain we are
filming this
a couple of weeks before and so to cover
ourselves just in case it released it
gets announced
that's this that's this section here
what if uh
because the edge cover hasn't been
revealed yet and it could be a big one
it could be
uh it could be the hollow knight silk
song so just in case it is
that would be wonderful that would be
wonderful for jordan but regardless it
probably wouldn't come out until 2021 i
would say on slack like for every event
like e3
pax nintendo directs i'm always just
posting like maybe
this will be the one maybe this will be
the one where they're like you know what
silk song is coming out in
six months on this day and it is never
that time well jordan
if you've been a good boy when santa
comes down his chimney
maybe he'll have a piece of paper with a
digit or cold for hollow knight silk
song on it
i'm just tired now tam i'm just tired
the piece of paper will actually say
just the word no chance on it
[Laughter]
and then you'll be like santa why aren't
you wearing a mask i don't ever want to
see it again
ever and if you don't do it you're fired
and i see you do it again you're
gone 99 99 of the reason why i want silk
song is for me but like the last the
last one percent is for
you tam because i want them to address
all the problems that you had with the
first hollow knights that you can play
it because
hollow knight is such your game it is a
game
about a society falling apart in the
wake of an
infection with a dream-like state i'm
like it is a metroidvania bloodborne and
the fact that you don't like it breaks
my heart
i don't i didn't say i don't like it i
just found it there's enough
annoying things in there that i was like
this is this is frustrating me right now
i'll come back to it when i have more
time i'm actually downloading it i have
it downloaded on my switch
for uh for this break oh okay
so could be you know this could be the
the time that you finally get into it
maybe next year
your tv behind you won't have bloodborne
anymore oh maybe i'll have something
else on there
maybe i'll have bloodborne too i was
do you want to talk about what what game
you're most looking forward to oh my
game
i doubt you could even imagine it oh my
god
which commanded the stars giving life
its fullest brilliance the elden ring
oh ellen ring shattered
like your dreams or something don't
be demonetized if evan just plays the
trailer yeah she's playing the trailer
no we should be okay yeah we'll be fine
elder ring is elden ring is my
my the game that i'm most excited about
seeing who knows
i was gonna say are you so sure that
it's coming out next year
oh whether or not it was coming out next
year i have to believe it
i haven't yeah
i've got very few things left in this
existence that is keeping me
hanging on to life else is one of them
if that doesn't show up next year you
know what
you might need to find a new managing
editor for game spot
i don't like this conversation
without elven ring this is what happens
do we need to have an intervention
do i need to reach out to someone look
up at the sky
it burns um yeah i'm excited for
i hope it comes down to the very least
we'll see it i kind of
think that it might um it's been in
development for long enough
but then again there's the things where
you know um they say it's the biggest
it's it's meant to be on a scale that
they haven't tried before
it's going to be open world um
supposedly and
in my mind i've got the idea that
they've basically gone
what we've made games about single
fallen kingdoms all this time
what if we made one fat off game with
multiple
fallen kingdoms in there and then
imagine like zelda
but each dungeon is a dark souls game
imagine that you go to one place and
you're like this is you know
lordran you go to another place you're
like what's going on here what why
what has the elden rings destruction
caused over here
and it's bloodborne you're like oh i
don't know
i think this is the problem having seen
nothing
say you're hyping yourself or something
like that might not even be true
yeah miyazaki shows up is that i made a
clicker game it's called elden ring
plays yourself at this point you've just
kind of become the personification of
arsenal
i am r eldon ring it's me i'm full of
the memes
i am me and daley olden ring update lad
just who seems lovely by the way he's
yeah i've been chatting to him
um we had it we had a nice dm
conversation we're homies now
because we share um we're talking about
alden ring news
um who does the elden ring update uh on
on youtube
we've given them a shout out yeah we've
got a michelle yeah don't go over there
yeah youtube.com uh hit up uh it's
called the channel's called eldering
news
um but yeah we we were chatting
throughout the game awards and
commiserating together um me and him are
just like
the embodiment of that reddit now yeah
well i guess
the thing is is that now you understand
how
a song of ice and fire fans feel and
it's kind of
intensified that because he's also
working on alden rings the thing about
the thing about the song it's on fire
like
the last thing that you know we had from
from software was amazing like it
was securo and demon souls the last
thing we had in the
song of ice and fire universe is poop
from a butt
so in his defense
george backed away from game of thrones
the show a long time ago
i was excited for the last book or the
latest book and then the
show finished i was like i don't get
single [ __ ] about any of this anymore
it is wild god we really have got a
tangent here haven't we
but it is wild how much how big the fall
from grace game of thrones was
it's it's almost as if season eight was
eternal sunshine from people
and it's just like oh wouldn't it be
great if you know there was a tv show of
uh song of ice and fire i think that
would be really
really cool but it's okay because hbo
are making a prequel series next year
whatever
so elder ring obviously hollow knight
sulk song
yep mine uh is a game that we
at least at this point know is going to
be released next year and that is the
next
god of war i was
i i kind of go through these phases
where i want to replay god of war
because i played it twice
um but i never went for the platinum and
that's always kind of been um
it's kind of always been eating away at
me and i was even looking at guides
yesterday but i know nothing about that
game
beyond what you can kind of put together
from how god of war 2018
ended but i just think god of war 2018
was so much it was so beautifully put
together
from the gameplay from the story to you
know creating an actual character
out of kratos and not just some
caricature
and maybe it's just because he's in
fortnight now and i'm seeing kratos
everywhere
flossing alongside the master and master
chief just turn around
um but if it is ragnarok that they are
doing which is
hinted at at the end of the last game i
think also i'm reading norse mythology
by
neil bloody gaiman so it's like it's all
i can think about
um corey corey if you're listening corey
there needs to be a hammer pulled you
off joke in there
if there isn't gonna be very upset corey
so we know right now that that game is
coming out
next year and i think one of the reasons
i picked it because my other game that
i'm super super looking forward to is
gotham knights
because i can't believe it's been so
long since we've had
a batman game um but even though
batman's not in this one
i know has it been that long yeah i was
like i was about 250. oh my god
oh my god i'm actually so hard yeah i
know i know i know but i know batman's
not in it but it will have
the arkham fighting and it will be set
in gotham
et cetera came this close again i'm
actually this close i could feel it
that would be my other pick but i
ultimately went for god of war because
one of the things i've noticed is that
going from playing astro bart and
miles morales and spider-man to playing
third-party games
like assassin's creed valhalla and
cyberpunk 2077
the difference in how games are using
the dual sense
is really is so vast playing these
first-party games that
have been designed and have the dual
sense compatibility like programmed in
having all the vibration having the
noises and stuff just feels
so cool and then you play a game like
valhalla or cyberpunk where just there
is
no vibration half the time and it just
feels really weird like i'm on this dirt
bike in the middle of the badlands and
i'm getting no feedback
from doing this sick jump or i'm getting
no feedback from my weapons or anything
that was a real big thing in valhalla
just feels like you're swinging into
thin air um and so that's why i'm really
looking forward to god of war because i
imagine that sony santa monica are
actually
thinking about that stuff and putting it
in and i think out of everyone
sony first party studios are gonna be
the people who will be doing
really cool things with that tech so
lucy's like how did i deal with this
peasantry for
so
yeah so that's that's why i picked god
of war
okay let's go on to what we hope to see
from the consoles themselves what
features what improvements
jordan come to your xbox all right for
xbox
i want them to implement more of their
labels on the games like the little
yeah the badges those are the calls
thank you so they are currently have the
one for
if it's xs enhanced or like it has
upgrades for the new consoles or if it's
on game pass or if it's with games with
gold but there's still room for a few
more
and i think a really cool one would be
for games that support quick resume just
like a
q r something like that just on the
square on the tile for the game so you
know
immediately whether or not the game that
you have
like supports quick resume and it will
just
save your spot when you decide to switch
over to apex legends or rocket league or
something like that
you want those games to look like boy
scouts
when they have badges on them all those
badges
i love labels i love lists i live for
that
do you remember the batman arkham yes
arkham city um the oh my god
game of the year edition yeah just not a
single bit of negatives
in there just logos up the wazoo
yeah we want it we want to look like
that that's a good that's a good one i
want that too because
right now it's sure
maybe the messaging around everything
has been quite confusing and difficult
to follow
and i mean we're in the space so we are
uh
we have we have to follow that stuff all
the time you see it on twitter you see
it
at work but if you're someone who's not
uh very online perpetually online
it's so easy for a smart person
so that would be a great fix time what
about you
my one is a simple one and it is the
playstation 5's game base which is
just a nightmare like i hate it so much
i just wanted remember when
on the ps4 where you could press a
button and then see your friends list
and it was just there and you'd be like
oh there's my friends
now you open that and it's like here's
every party that you've ever been
associated with
and we're gonna bury all your friends in
there but sometimes we'll put one of
your friends up here because you
we think he's might like this friend but
then the next time you turn it on that
friend's not gonna be there
all i want is my friends list online
offline
if you want to put like parties at the
bottom that's fine if i have to like put
a little button at the top that's like
press this to see your parties
and i'll press it see my part is i don't
want to constantly see
every party that anyone on my friend's
list is is part of or that i'm part of
leave it out let's clean that up
sony um yeah okay
i'll i agree with that i'll allow it
mine mine is also um
sort of friends related i have two
uh i got two friends what is your
problem with friends
one of mine is given that there are so
many games now that support
cross-platform play
just please put discord discord on
consoles
it would be great i would love to have a
cross
party chat i know in some games you can
have
cross platform part i think you can have
cross-platform parties like you can have
group chat
in-game but i think it would be really
cool if you could just have discord
yeah because i use it a lot that's a
great one but also
my other suggestion is and actually this
is something that xbox has and
playstation
doesn't and i would love for playstation
to have this too it is a feature where
when you take a screenshot on xbox
it automatically uploads it to your
phone
and i think playstation wonderful
playstation 100 do that because
it makes crafting tweets and getting
screenshots so much easier
and just having all of that stuff on
your phone fantastic
so kudos xbox step up playstation
what are your wild card predictions for
2021 this is
this is for the dreamers but jordan i'll
come to you first
we'll we'll pause the dream for a second
okay so 2021
is going to be a good year
i hope i pray i know in my heart for
bioware
then we're gonna get like another
trailer for dragon age we're gonna find
out that the new mass effect game is a
sequel to
andromeda and like we're gonna get the
legendary edition
and most importantly of all anthem 2.0
is going to come out
with a next-gen update for the game and
it will be
good not great not phenomenal but it
will be good
so
i love that jordan dreaming big anthem
will come out and it will be absolutely
fine
it will i you could have said you could
have said it would be amazing
we're organizing
i mean is it not in bioware's best
interest
and i and i say this knowing that
hundreds of people worked on that game
i don't want to sh i don't want to shoot
on it at all i actually really
i think anthem had a lot of great ideas
but is it within
you know should they just drop it at
this point or do you really think there
is that
final fantasy 14 esque redemption story
that's just waiting to happen
see i i don't think it's there i don't
think there's like a ff14
redemption arc to anthem but i think
that they can recover and deliver
something that's at least good in like
before games like avowed and elder
scrolls six and star
field start coming in and dominating the
conversation upcoming rpgs
bioware can just be like we came back
and we fixed our
loot based shooter and added some nice
story
based rpg elements to it the stuff that
we know that you people like
and i think they can salvage that and
have a decent 2021 while we're
anxiously awaiting some news about mass
effect and dragon age
yeah i would like to see it come back
and do really well because like lucy
said like there's
the fundamentals of that game were there
like the flight stuff felt good until
you crashed the earth yeah and then i
was just like oh my god why are you
doing this
um but yeah i don't know like i want it
to be there but i don't i feel like i'll
struggle to care
especially in a year when like other
major
rpgs are coming out and also games and
service titles are coming out i'm just
like
you had your chance move on i mean
speaking of mass effect i'm so
i keep forgetting that legendary
edition's only really been rated for
do we still call it current gen ps4 and
xbox one i say last gen now last gen now
i find that very surprising i assume the
next gen patches will be coming at some
point but
it's so strange it's so strange for me
to think of that game as a
ps4 xbox one game instead of a
current gen game but i
i agree with you i also really really
hope that is it's a great year for
bioware
because god knows they need it and god
knows the fans say we need it we need it
all right tam what's your dream metal
gear solid remake
from blue point studios it's gotta
happen
i mean there's been like rumors about it
forever
various people have said it's happening
and others said and they've been doing
some cryptic
tweeting recently that alludes to a
bunch of things
um and i feel like um
metal gear solid being brought back
right now is kind of perfect this is the
right time for it one because sony is
now like
well blue point knocked out of the park
with they have done with
uh um shadow of the colossus and demon
souls and sony's on this kind of like
absolute tear with bringing back iconic
playstation franchises that have been
formative moments in
the console's history and few of them
are
as formative as metal gear solid on the
playstation was
so that studio is the perfect studio
they worked on
um the hd remix of uh two three
um and i think paul warps as well maybe
or a peace walker one of those two they
did a hd collection
so they're familiar with the franchise
just to a degree um
and then it works out for konami as well
because konami is still facing an uphill
struggle
they've not committed to making big big
games if sony rolls up
and is like we've got this blank
checkbook um
and we'll do a lot of the heavy lifting
we've got a studio ready
and konami is like okay cool partnership
we benefit off of it
you know you get to rema you rain you
make the game and we get some good will
out of it
that's fine and then blue point roll up
they make that game my dream is for blue
point to become like i want sony to
roll up buy everything konami has and
turn blue point into konami 2.0
and just be like you make metal gear you
make silent hill you make
castlevania they're your franchises now
konami's over there making pachinko
money
but every now and then they're going to
come in and see if you cleaned your room
and you just go yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
and then they'll leave
um that's it i'm all for more remakes
that
allow me the baby to play a bunch of
games that i was too young to play the
first
dude that first metal gear oh my god if
they remade that i would cry
i think like a blue point remake of um
or a remake of metal gear with kojima's
involvement feels
doable as well like i feel like you
could be like hey mate we're gonna
remake your game you you want in and
he'll be like yeah i'll come in and make
sure this
you know the ship is going the right way
i can be a resource that you can hit up
he loves that kind of like collaborative
kind of thing
you know and he can kind of cement not
cement but like
give fans what they want i think if it
does happen
sony or whoever it is will make a point
of saying yeah kojima's involved he's
around he's like
every now and then he rolls up and is
like this is good i like this
i like his hair it's nice okay i think
that's a pretty great
i think that's a great dream to have tom
my dream
is that i hope that final fantasy 16
comes out next year
and that it's gonna be way sooner than
we anticipate
because there was there was these rumors
and stuff going on i think it was
official playstation magazine or game
reactor in the uk
posted oh final fantasy 16 is coming out
in
2021 which given that we only saw it
over the summer
when it was revealed i think everyone
just in their head
was like oh square enix announced a game
sure we'll see that in two three years
time but if it comes out next year i
would absolutely
love that i was i was legit listening to
the final fantasy 15 soundtrack all day
and given that it's under the watchful
gaze of yoshida-san
and the final fantasy 14 development
team who
and i'm not playing final fantasy 14
right now because
i i can't i i know that i'll get i'll
get sucked into it i know that i'll get
so sucked into it
but i started playing and it's good
that's the thing listening to
michael hyam listening to ben janka
john luke and everyone who plays it and
loves those games loves that game
i just think that given everything
they've learned
on recent final fantasies including
seven remake
and having the watchful gaze of the 14
team i think 16 especially because it
looks
dark as it's back to high fantasy which
is you know
not the modern stuff anymore sorry my
sweet boys
and your sweet car but i just think
it's weird to me that death loop god of
war gotham knights and final fantasy in
my most anticipated games right now
but my dream is that it comes out
q2 like just no nonsense just bam there
it is
another kudos to reference there is like
a bottom of a shoe
from a fantasy like the bottom of an
avatar
so that's it for our hopes and dreams
for 2021
you make it sound like our hopes and
dreams are coming to an
end i'm not coming to an end i'm just
saying that in the context of the
episode
those were our hopes and dreams of 2021.
what are you doing
2020 has thoroughly crushed all our
hopes and dreams
perhaps we'll be better off in 2021 we
go into 2021 as hollow husk human beings
with narya hope neri adrian oh you are
getting ready for holland
well he really is so
i've already said it i've already said
it let us know what you're most looking
forward to in 2021 and don't be afraid
to dream
hold on to those dreams don't be
like i don't i don't know you know what
i'm looking forward to in 2021
corona vaccine
so those are our hopes and dreams for
2021
beyond you know the world's slowly
healing and getting back
to a better place the world is healing
neutral healing
you know what i'm just going to roll
with that outro because this is like the
third one that we've done
but let us know what games and features
etc you're most looking forward to in
twitch which one in the comments below
and
i just wanted to say thank you all for
sticking with us for
almost 20 weeks of this ridiculous
but very very fun show that we've been
making
we'll be back in some form next year
uh it won't necessarily maybe be under
the generation x banner but we've got
some plans
not going to go into too much detail
right now but we'll be back
that's that's kind of like a really
james bond like
the generation next crew will return i
want to see i want
i want to see that exactly what you said
transcribed and used on the next marvel
movie
might be back i'm not sure in my form
but
uh nick fury uh we got some plans
so yes thank you everyone for watching
and
you know enjoying our stupid jokes and
being a really fun
audience uh jordan tam do you have
anything to say
yes i would like to thank uh our editor
evan langer who who
has been taught nobody has seen evan but
he's just like seven
for super buff like uh absolute editing
machine
he loves zelda so he wears like just
this massive
massive t-shirt like it's pulled across
his
rippling uh chest and it's just got
tingle on it
but evan is like evan's amazing yeah um
all the jokes that you love and you all
the quick edits and
fun stuff is basically because of him we
just say it and then he makes it funny
i say yeah the show's only good because
of evan all our bad jokes are cut away
yeah exactly thank you evan what have
you got say for yourself evan
well i just want to say there's some
very nice words tam
i uh didn't expect anything less from
you and for anybody listening to this
thank you so much for tuning in every
week
i had a blast working on this show and
uh yeah stay tuned for what the future
might hold
for game spot yeah but how much you've
benched though evan dude i benched like
30 tams
oh damn damn
wow all right i think that just about
does it thank you everyone again
we'll see you in the new year have a
wonderful holiday season bye
bye hot girl summer next generation